puissance et rencontrer un homme
qui doit l'emmener au camp de travail
ctt
je viens de l'ouest c'est ça avec les
choses qu'on peut très bien dans ce
coin-là
gens se battent entre eux
mais pourquoi et quand tu travailles
c'est bizarre comme destination c'est
censé être une occasion unique
mais qu'est ce qu'il ya j'aime rejoindre
vient voir ça
c'est vraiment de l'or on a prouvé défi
temps
nous deux va devoir aller chercher une
excavatrice pour la sortir
je crois que je vais rester avec l'or
il faut surveiller son nom faut se
protéger du soleil il sait pas une
partie de plaisir par ici
encore combien de temps
alors tu es tout seul ici vos petites
envol
a mal à la terre rond tout va commencer
à trembler grange
sacchi moscou tué ce qu'elle a vu lors
du cache quelque chose d'appris mois
dans la tête
parce que tu appuies tout près des plus
beaux spas témoin
c'est bordeaux
je me débrouillais